On August 19, 2020, Russian politician, Alexei
Navalny was shooting this campaign video.
He was in Siberia.
One of the many places where, in about 3 weeks,
there would be local and regional elections.
But he wasn’t running for office.
He was urging people to vote out the ruling
party, United Russia, led by the president,
Vladimir Putin.
He’s made many videos like this before and
they usually rack up millions of views.
It’s this ability to reach people via the
internet that has helped make Navalny the
face of Russia's opposition movement.
Soon after making his case in Siberia, he
got on a plane bound for Moscow.
But the plane was suddenly diverted to Omsk.
Navalny had been poisoned.
And collapsed on the plane.
An investigation later revealed that he had
been poisoned with Novichok, a highly-toxic
nerve agent, that was developed by the Soviet
Union in the 1970s.
It was also used, likely by Russia in 2018
to attack Sergei Skirpal, a former spy.
Navalny survived the assassination attempt
and set off a movement unlike any in recent
history.
So how did he do it?
And why is he such a big threat to Putin?
On December 31, 1999, Putin became the President
of Russia.
The Soviet Union had collapsed just 8 years
earlier and the new Russian Federation was
slowly transitioning to democracy.
Previously, Putin had been a spy in the Soviet
KGB and head of the Russian security service.
Roles that shaped how he wanted to govern
as President.
So, he was trying to remake Russia in the image
of the KGB.
Like if everything in the world could be as
centralized, insular, and secretive as the
KGB, it would work well.
So in order to maximize his control, Putin
surrounded himself with the most powerful
elements in Russia.
Starting with the media.
Police were sent into Russia’s independent
media companies, charging their owners, and
bringing newsrooms under state control.
After federal television, it went on to regional
television and then, it went to print newspapers.
It was like a flesh eating machine.
Whatever it could see that was functioning
independently, it would gobble up next.
This hid Putin’s actions from the public
so he was able to go after another powerful
element - Russia’s elections.
His regime manipulated who could run for office.
And that typically meant Putin’s party and
a few fake candidates, sanctioned by the regime.
This was designed to splinter the opposition
vote.
And on top of that,
The vote counting is rigged.
Meaning that it was nearly impossible to run
against Putin or his party.
And that United Russia had control of the
central and local governments all across the country.
But politicians weren’t the only threat
to Putin.
He also went after Russia's oligarchs and
their prominent friends to weed out some powerful
critics.
In the early 2000s, most of Russia’s wealth
was concentrated in the hands of a few, very
powerful men.
Putin protected those that swore loyalty to
him.
And those who didn't were either arrested
on trumped up charges or mysteriously killed.
So, the most common way to get rid of somebody.
Is to bring them up on embezzlement charges.
Former Russian oil tycoon, Mikhail Khodorkovsky,
has been found guilty of embezzlement.
Russian tycoon, Boris Berezovsky, convicted
of embezzlement.
A former Russian business man, he was accused
of embezzling money, Nikolay Glushkov, the
cause of death is still unexplained.
That's how the judiciary is weaponized.
With the law on his side, within a decade,
Putin insulated himself with the most powerful
elements on all sides.
And it was all held together by corruption.
Corruption is a structural feature of the
regime.
It's not an inefficiency of the regime.
It's not a drag on the regime.
It's the core of the regime.
According to a report, over $400 billion were
lost to corruption in Russia between 2000
and 2008.
But because Putin controlled the media, much
of it was hidden.
Until a young lawyer named Alexei Navalny
found a way to change that.
In 2006, Navalny started a blog where he wrote
about corruption.
In 2010, he wrote that at least $4 billion
was stolen out of the state-owned transportation
company, Transneft.
And he had proof.
He had bought stock in the company and was
able to access internal documents
that plainly showed how government money was
funneled into offshore accounts owned
by Transneft officials.
And this was just the beginning.
Navalny soon published investigations on corrupt
oil schemes, land deals, and fraud at state-owned
banks by Russian oligarchs and politicians.
By posting straight to his blog, Navalny was
circumventing state media to reveal corruption
and expose Putin’s regime in a way that
Russians had never seen before.
All the while making a name for himself.
Like he thought that corruption was
something knowable.
That that you could learn about it, you could
systematize it.
And, again, you could take it seriously.
And I said, you know what?
I think we now have an actual politician in
this country.
In 2011, huge protests erupted when Putin’s
party won a majority in parliament despite
reports of voter fraud.
It was the largest wave of demonstrations
Putin’s regime had ever faced.
And Navalny was one of the main organizers.
He was building on his investigations by speaking
out publicly against corruption.
State television ignored the protests even
as the police arrested more than 1,000 people
and went after the organizers.
One of the other ones was jailed, several
were forced into exile, one was murdered,
Boris Nemstov.
And Navalny was the last guy standing.
Over time, he developed a talent for organizing
protests and gained a following.
Then in 2013, he ran for mayor of Moscow.
And it stirred some controversy.
He had participated in Russian nationalist
marches in the past.
And used ethnic slurs when referring to Russian
minorities.
But people were still drawn to the main message
of his campaign.
State TV didn’t give his campaign any airtime,
so he relied on rallies, online crowdsourcing,
and an army of volunteers to spread the word.
But, just as he was gaining momentum, police
arrested him on trumped-up charges of embezzlement
and sentenced him to 5 years in jail.
His supporters flooded the streets in protest.
Navalny was eventually released on bail and
didn't win the election.
But, he went on to finish second place.
He continued to expose corruption through
Youtube videos.
Like this one, in 2017, on the extreme wealth
of Putin's ally, Dmitri Medvedev.
It reached millions and sparked another round
of protests.
At the same time, Navalny was running for
office again.
This time, against Putin for President.
Predictably, the regime struck back and disqualified
him based on the previous embezzlement charges.
Further revealing just how rigged Russia’s
laws and elections were.
But in 2020, Navalny found a way to take on
the whole electoral system.
He called it Smart-Voting.
Instead of letting the opposition vote splinter
among several dummy candidates, Navalny identified
one candidate and urged people to vote for
the same one, even if they were backed by
Putin's regime.
It takes an incredible amount of public trust
and charisma to get people to
unify behind a meaningless candidate.
But, its true, if you get enough people to do it, it
actually can add up to meaningful resistance.
And it terrifies the Kremlin.
During that time, Navalny was the second most
popular politician in all of Russia according
to some polls.
While Putin’s favorability ratings were
slipping because of a struggling economy.
That made Navalny a threat.
And it explains why he was poisoned, possibly
more than once.
Once he was very weirdly ill and once his
wife, Yulia, was very weirdly ill.
They were looking for an opportunity, a place
and a time and it finally seemed like it was
almost perfect.
But I think they did expect that they would be
rid of him by now and they're not.
After the Siberia attack, Navalny recovered
in a German hospital where he miraculously
survived.
A few months later, he went back to his investigations.
In December 2020, he tricked the secret agent
who poisoned him into revealing how he did
it.
Then, in January, he returned to Russia knowing
he would be arrested.
Police met him at the airport, and charged
him with violating the parole from his 2014
embezzlement case.
While detained, his team released another
video, this one attacking Putin directly.
It’s been viewed over 100 million times.
His supporters flooded the streets in over
100 cities across Russia.
A few days later, Navalny was sentenced to
2 years and 8 months in prison, sparking even
more protests.
Police have arrested more than 5,000 people
while state media has downplayed it.
Even though Navalny ended up in prison again,
his movement continued to play out on the
streets.
By exposing Putin's regime for a decade, Navalny
might have found a way to build a movement
that could outlast his freedom.